salve galera me disseram que 90% todo
mundo daqui a flamenguista é verdade
bom é é função para todo mundo
corintiano
- o luis bom é muito bom estar aqui
eu queria agradecer muito a um amigo
muito querido que é o arapuan que é um
orgulho ver um jovem liderando com muita
habilidade universidade tão grande e
tendo uma equipe engajada tão apaixonada
como é que faz coisas incríveis
acontecerem como trazer o próprio ted
pra cá eu estou muito feliz também
dividir palco com gente como luiz que
faz a coisa acontecer no brasil como o
próprio andré e essa gente toda bonita
que está aqui que eu fico muito
inspirado eu queria começar a minha fala
dizendo que eu li um livro que tenha
inspirado muito é um dos melhores livros
que eu já vi na minha vida de volta ao
mundo em três escolas
escrito por uma porrada de gente legal e
cruz inclusive andré gravatar
a camila pisa a carla mayumi o eduardo
shinohara
queria começar a palestra lendo um poema
que o meu amigo andré que faz parte do
global shapers do fórum econômico
mundial escreveu e é tão bom dialogar
com as rádios para tentar ensinar e esse
poema me toca muito porque é um jovem
querendo mudar o mundo querendo mudar o
brasil como que isso tem que ser real
nessa década que a gente vive ele
escreveu isso educação é feita
principalmente de gente gente é feita
principalmente à abundância
freire disse que se a educação não pode
tudo alguma coisa fundamental ela pode
ea educação pode uma potência que surgiu
um bem antes de método o ciência a
educação tem a potência
o esticamento do olhar para que ele se
abra enorme do tamanho do mar
a educação tem a potência da expansão do
cultivo de campos de diversidade para
fertilizar os sertões que hoje tem nome
de cidade
a educação tem a potência do desafio
amento passa pelo encontro com nossos
redemoinhos internos que giram sem
trégua no movimento de 'bagunça' são
daquelas entranhas feitas principalmente
pela emoção
a educação tem a potência de instaurar
uma captação de horizontes dentro de
cada um para que as abundâncias sejam
descobertas lapidadas expostas
caleidoscópio padacké tocadas abertas
compartilhadas
a educação tem a potência de conjugar o
verbo sinuoso em chamas
o verbo ousar de ar que é o verbo de
significância verbo de propósito sem
demora para que nos ousadia de emos no
agora e no gerúndio ousadia e ando a
qualquer hora
andré botafogo fica de pé por favor uma
salva de palmas para exporta
jovens ordinário para falar de educação
eu tive uma grande professora que mudou
a minha vida e eu quero dizer três ou
quatro coisas que essa mulher me ensinou
que mudou a minha história e foi a
grande professora da minha vida e que
isso pode nos tempos atuais impulsionar
a educação pra frente a primeira lição
que eu tive na vida
foi assim que eu nasci depois que eu
nasci meus pais me levaram pra morar
dentro de um barraco numa favela em
guarulhos são paulo eu venho dessa
favela da década de 80 que tudo era
barraco ea grana lá em casa era tão
pouca que meu pai minha mãe não teve
condição de comprar um deles e me
colocaram para dormir nos primeiros nove
meses de vida dentro de uma banheira
azul e o que me faltava naquele espaço
eram referências pessoas pelas quais eu
pudesse olhar e dizer eu quero ser igual
e sujeito então do lado esquerdo da
minha casa morava o traficante lá direi
da minha casa moravam assassino ap líder
a sete dedos
um dia eu fui para a escola e vi que
três dedos da mão dele tinha sido
arrancado não sei como e quando ia
dormir à noite eu sonhava que vive
fuzilava acordava me bater no meio da
noite e aquilo tudo era muito horrível e
tem uma frase que diz assim ok w se você
acha que está muito ruim
cuidado que ainda pode ficar pior e pior
ainda bateu na porta de casa quando meu
pai é iludido por isso a conjuntura
social acabou ingressando nas drogas
tornou dependente da cocaína e do crack
e acabou embarcando no pior dos mundos
que o mundo crime meu pai se tornou um
assaltante foi preso e indiciado por
roubo
a caa bom com formação de quadrilha e
assalto à mão armada agora imagine você
pobre favelado estudante de escola
pública e filho de um bandido
o que a sociedade não imaginava que eu
seria tudo menos o que eu sou hoje
sociedade sociedade mais nova parceria
qualquer coisa menos um jornalista -
escritor - roteirista - empreendedor
social - eleito pelo fórum
o nome de alguém pode mudar o brasil
para melhor e menos alguém que acabou de
sair na lista da revista forbes como um
dos 30 jovens mais influentes do país
com menos de 30 anos
então eu tenho um nome a sociedade como
um todo mundo imaginava que eu ia pra cá
que eu ia por pior que ia para aquilo
que não prestava que eu ia para lançar a
sociedade pra baixo eu voltei e fui pra
algo maior
vai como que eu fiz essa mágica como que
sai do nada e vai pra algo maior por
conta de uma preta que a minha rainha
que me ensinou algumas coisas e é a
primeira lição que a minha rainha me
ensinou a minha maior locadora é que
todos os dias nós acordávamos um barraco
minha mãe olhava pra mim me dizia filho
amanhã vou tentar julgar por conta do
espaço onde tu vive e pelo espaço em teu
pai tá mas nada disso pode diminuir a
tua garra tua criatividade ea sua
capacidade de fazer tudo pode
minha mãe me disse uma frase que me
ressignifica ou ela disse não importa de
onde você vem
o que importa para onde você vai na vida
e você pode ir para um lugar alto você
pode ir pro muito e essa é possivelmente
uma das principais lições que a educação
tem que dizer para esse menino que vem
da periferia que vive num espaço onde
não têm cinema não tem teatro não tem
pista de skate não tem um estúdio social
para gravar o cd não tem curso de inglês
não tem empresa gerando mão de obra e
capacitando jovens
não tenho nada tem um ócio só só tem um
vazio ea educação tem que dizer para
esse jovem que ele pode ter vindo do
abandono do nada do esquecimento mas a
educação pode levar ele pro tudo aquilo
que é grande para aquilo que é maior
para se inspirar a dor para ser a
primeira pessoa na família têm um
diploma para ser empreendedor do bairro
que vai gerar a mãe que vai gerar um
posto de trabalho para aquele menino que
podia entrar no tráfico então a educação
eo professor tem que resgatar esse papel
de dizer projovem o
onde você vem não importa o que importa
é pra onde você pode ir na sua vida ea
segunda lição que a minha mãe me ensinou
é que eu podia viver no pior lugar num
num espaço totalmente influenciado pelo
crime e pela dor da edição e pela
violência mas o que é tangibilizar e o
que editar minha vida não é onde eu
morava mas o que morava dentro de mim
então aos sete anos de idade uma que o
maior gol da minha vida que foi embora
eu tenha nascido e morador dentro da
favela eu nunca deixei que a favela com
seus pontos negativos
morace dentro de mim então eu morava
nela mas ela não morava dentro de mim eu
vivia nela mas ela não vivia dentro de
mim
e alguém pode me perguntar edu e o que
vivia dentro de você
respondo o que sempre esteve dentro de
mim me jogando pra frente foi essa
história do sonho grande da criatividade
da ousadia da garra e do entusiasmo que
essa palavra no original do grego
significa deus morando dentro de você e
te empurrando com algo maior
então esse é fundamentalmente um dos
papéis da educação de dizer pro jovem
não é onde você mora pode morar num
puxadinho uma casa sem reboco e no
espaço onde você vive pode não ter
infraestrutura alguma mais o que vai
narrar a tua vida é o que mora dentro de
você e se dentro dessa gente que está no
ensino médio que está embarcando na
faculdade às vezes sem propostas sem
rumo mas se dentro delas moral essa
coisa do sonho grande de ser criativo de
ser usado de se aberto para o novo as
pessoas avançam e muda o rumo da sua
própria vida ea terceira grande lição
que a minha mãe me ensinou
aqui no primeiro dia que eu botei o pé
dentro de uma faculdade meu professor
pediu para que todos os alunos
escrevesse um texto eu fui o primeiro a
concluir e botei na mesa dele professor
começou a ler
e no meio do texto ele parou olhou pra
mim e disse ser do mais você tem certeza
que é ser jornalista eu disse sim um
sonho grande ele falou vou te dar um
conselho
desista desse sonho porque tu escreve
muito mal seu texto é horrível e não tem
chance alguma ser jornalista e voltei
para casa estudar usada porque não foi
com você eu voltei pra casa revoltado e
é incrível como mãe parece que tem um
radar na cabeça e ela consegue detectar
justamente aquilo que você tem sempre
que o diga uma única palavra pra ela né
assim tudo de tecto que o [ __ ] tinha
lá e aí minha mãe diz filho que é que tu
tem foi internada no filme conto tem
alguma coisa um cara bem o flamengo
realmente não estou bem
professor violentou minhas emoções diz
que não tem chance alguma de ser
jornalista minha mãe se levantou bruta e
diz três coisas a primeira profissão
burro a segunda ele é um idiota aí até
chorei por um babaca e falou filho
inclusive se ele estivesse aqui eu dava
uma surra nele e na maioria para mim
falou assim isso foi determinante me
ressignifica ou me empurrou ela olhou
pra mim e disse filho
eu acredito em você e isso basta
foi o que fiz eu te gerei e eu sei onde
isso vai chegar e eu sei pra que tudo
foi feito vai longe volta
influenciado por minha mãe na capacidade
dela acredita em mim e eu voltei pra
faculdade da faculdade eu escrevi um
livro e desse livro de se discutir o
brasil em âmbito político cultural e
religioso entrevistar gente que nenhum
aluno ainda na história da universidade
te entrevistado do hotel mochila nas
costas ainda estudante sair viajando o
brasil para discutir o brasil com gente
boa e gente ruim
e aí eu consegui entrevistar
pessoalmente no sonho grande ousadia o
ex presidente da república fernando
collor de mello ex vice presidente no
governo fernando henrique cardoso marco
maciel o ex prefeito do rio de janeiro
cesar maia o ex ministro da casa civil
josé dirceu
representante do papa no brasil dom
dimas lara o presidente da assembléia de
deus no brasil josé wellington bezerra
da costa ator da globo juca de oliveira
o escritor augusto cury o escritor
fernando morais ea marina silva e aí o
livro conseguiu influenciar conseguiu
impactar e conseguiu provar que o aluno
pode fazer mais e teve um dia que eu fui
no mac donald kohn e se um prêmio de
responsa bom dia tentou comer um lanche
no mac tinha grana ele falou puxa os
preços da favela voltou à favela e
construir uma ferramenta chamada o mec
favela e construiu em são paulo contará
com muita fome sujeito de espuma anthony
maior larica que ele construiu um
chamado mac larica e foi um sucesso de
venda acontece a história e registrei no
itaú cultural com curriculum da puc usp
tudo quanto é lugar e fui vencedor
eleito repórter revelação pelo instituto
itaú cultural
aí quando eu olho para trás e depois
disso tanta coisa aconteceu na minha
vida fundar um instituto inspirar mais
de 200 pessoas dentro de favelas de são
paulo que irá mão de obra gerar emprego
fazer parte de debates com líderes
nacionais escrever livros e mais de 1
milhão de acessos no youtube e óleo e
penso não tem nada de mim e tem muito da
minha educadora que teve a capacidade de
acreditar em mim quando o doutor disse
que eu não tinha chance de ser um grande
jornalista
eu vejo que foi pouco da minha
inteligência e muito mais da capacidade
da minha preta da minha rainha e olhar
nos meus olhos e dizer eu acredito em
você eu sei que tu pode e essa tem que
ser a marca da educação no país é
acreditar
essa tem que ser a grande diretrizes de
quem educa olhar nos olhos dos jovens
que às vezes chegou na escola marli mar
comendo um pão com manteiga num café
certo fraquinho olhar para esse jovem
acreditar que ele pode ser um médico que
ele pode ser um juiz que ele pode ser um
governador da transparência que ele pode
ser alguém que vai receber unificar a
relação humana que vai fazer mais que
vai fazer melhor
a gente tá todo dia e cada vez mais
perdendo a nossa capacidade de acreditar
no país melhor e acreditar que a
educação pode mas essa coisa de
acreditar é que faz pessoas comuns fazem
coisas extraordinárias
essa coisa é acreditar é que faz o
pedido da favela sair de lá eu só vou
pro brasil inteiro essa coisa de
acreditar foi de tanto a acreditar que
alguém ficou incomodado com frio e
construiu ar condicionado
foi de tanto acreditar que alguém ficou
incomodado com a escuridão construiu a
lâmpada
foi de tanto acreditar que alguém ficou
incomodado com a distância e construir o
carro ficou incomodado com tranças com
seu avião ficou incomodado com a demora
o povo com sua internet depois construiu
o item o facebook os blogs vlogs e como
é que tomo do mundo pra melhor mas é
coisa de gente maluca que dizer eu
acredito e não tem um bem que tire isso
da cabeça dessa pessoa ele acreditou e
aí no brasil na educação em todos os
setores a gente tem duas bandas de gente
uma a banda de gente que finge que
acredita que vai falar atua junto tô
nessa mas no primeiro problema desanima
foi fora lagamar mou e tenho a outra
banda de gente que faz que tenta mas não
tem grana mas o cara tem muito ele entra
a matar ferrado mas ele vai brigar com o
prefeito da cidade
ah mas não tem jeito ele vai obrigar até
com o reitor mas ele consegue implantar
a inovação na sala de aula é gente que
tá chovendo ele vai remendo telhado mas
eles não vão perceber a nós vamos
acreditar porque não estamos aqui para
construir um brasil melhor
essa gente que acredita que faz o brasil
ser grande ea última coisa que a minha
mãe me ensinou é que eu tenho que sair é
que eu tinha que ir atrás do novo um dia
eu acabei decidindo escreveu um livro
chamado jovens falcões e aí eu fui na
minha mãe no meu pai falou mãe para o
que escrever um livro tem que viajar o
brasil meu pai disse vai mas não tem um
real para te arrumar mas raj
a mãe foi o filho fao e aí eu juntei um
grupo de amigos porque ainda não tinha
grana até hoje não tenho muito mais para
ver e eu vendi meu note notebook celular
calça jeans mantém um comitê juventude
foi o trabalho de segurança anunciou que
me trouxeram grande e eu sair viajando o
brasil descobriu a história de jovens
incríveis que do nada chegou a tudo que
resultou no meu livro chamado jovens
falcões publicado com prefácio do
marcelo tas que um amigo muito querido
contracapa do luisão entrou para a lista
dos mais inspiradores de 2012 e a grande
lição que eu tive eu tive que sair
debaixo da saia da minha mãe eu tive que
sair daquele bairro que me deram pra
morar no quarto que meu pai construiu
pra mim e quando eu saí eu comecei a
voar e nessa e um às vezes não via como
resolver meus problemas eu começava a
cair no despenhadeiro e aí eu gritava e
dizia mãe e minha mãe não estava lá para
me ajudar
e foi nesse momento que não tem ninguém
para me ajudar que eu fiz aquela
transição de ser menino que jogava
bolinha de gude no campinho para ser um
empreendedor social que deixei de ser um
menino que empinava pipa no bairro pra
ser alguém que ajudar a melhorar o meu
país
foi nessa de não ter ninguém nessa de
tentar um novo nessa de sair de dentro
de casa nessa de quebrar um ninho que me
deram que eu comecei a deixar de ser
menino e viram um homem o que a gente
precisa é sair da zona de conforto o que
a gente precisa é sair de dentro da sala
de aula das quatro paredes o que a gente
precisa é atrás de algo maior
o que a gente precisa é acordar cedo com
aquela paixão com a vibração que como
diz une lança a única coisa que vi bem
você for seu celular
época coisa tá ruim então a gente
precisa sair com aquela vibração dia
atrás do do lugar onde a gente não tocou
de sentir o cheiro que a gente ainda não
sentiu e viver porque quando tudo sai do
espaço que te deram tudo vivido conhece
e não tem nada melhor do que você trate
a outro mundo não tem nada melhor do que
você conhece uma outra
palavra o que eu acho mais poderoso na
vida é quando você não é só
caetano veloso é quando você caetano
veloso mas você também é [ __ ] você
também emicida você não é só filé mignon
mas ele também é escondidinho ele também
é o ovo ele não é só jardins e também
não é só o morumbi ele também é capão
redondo e cidade tiradentes é morro do
vidigal é complexo do alemão
quando a gente não é só um tipo de
poesia ele é carlos drumond de andrade
mas ele também a sérgio vaz e isso que
vai fazer sujeito foi maior quando ele
consegue viver o mundo viver vida se
deixar se permitir conhecer se permitir
sentir o outro cheiro que não seja só o
perfume da diesel do caracu mas ele sabe
outras coisas ele tem outras fragâncias
é essa gente que elimina preconceito
todo dia que consegue abraçar o preto eo
preto consegue eliminar preconceito e
abraçar o branco do morumbi
essa gente que elimina preconceito e
vive e toca e sai do lugar e remo em
outra direção e caminha que vai
descobrir um novo essa gente que vai
voltar depois para o bairro onde vive
para a faculdade e um trabalha para a
sala de aula onde leciona e como ele foi
dizer quando ele foi ensaiar quando ele
for lecionar não é só uma aula é uma
poesia é uma obra cinematográfica é um
canto ele está entregando é vida para as
pessoas a inspiração é transformação
pessoal houve ele nunca mais esquece a
mesma
a pessoa ouve ele e disse eu tô pequeno
mas dá para ficar maior
eu tô rui vai dar pra ir pra algo muito
bom
acredito que todo mundo pode mudar o
mundo seja você professor e chefe de
cozinha pedreiro o minha mãe que é
diarista e que me fez um homem de
verdade todo mundo condutta lotado de
propósito como tá lotado de sonho grande
conta lotado de uma fé conta lotado de
uma certeza de que veio pro mundo mais
do que fazer peso pode revolucionar e
fazer a diferença
obrigado galera